[Music]
so donald trump and alex jones and a
whole lot of other people are no longer
allowed on twitter but justin trudeau is
he's the prime minister of canada now
that's unfair of course but it's also
interesting because trudeau is way
crazier than any of the people who've
been banned from twitter that we're
aware of but you can see him think in
real time and that's kind of cool it
tells you a lot he just sent this tweet
out quote people across the country are
lighting candles to honor indigenous
women girls and
two s l g b t q q i a plus plus
now that's a group a so-called community
most of these communities by the way
consist of people who've got nothing in
common with each other and don't even
know each other there are no meetings or
anything they're not real communities
they're constructs of politicians but
whatever
what the hell is he talking about
what are the chances justin trudeau has
no idea what he's talking about he's not
even sure how you're supposed to say
that acronym watch
i will never apologize for standing up
for an lgdp l
gt lbg
lgbtq2 plus uh kids rights
it's all pretty great also a little
terrifying god saad is a very
interesting personal professor author of
the new book the parasitic mind how
infectious ideas are killing common
sense and boy is that true professor
thanks so much for coming on we
appreciate your being here so what do
you make of the prime minister of canada
coming out with a
vehement defense of an endorsement of a
group whose name he can't even pronounce
or define
well it's part and parcel of his moral
confusion and moral hypocrisy when he
was a parliamentarian when stephen
harper was prime minister
justin trudeau got very upset because
stephen harper referred to honor
killings and child bride and female
genital mutilation as barbaric justin
trudeau wasn't angry at those acts he
was angry that stephen bar uh that
stephen harper would call them barbaric
so that gives you a sense
of his moral compass
so this it's not about protecting human
rights which i think all of us would be
strongly for i certainly would it's
about elevating some groups and hurting
others
indeed uh and i mean i see this all
through my scientific career it is no
longer about judging the uh when you
apply for a scientific grant it's no
longer about the
the worth of the scientific application
it's about whether you adhere to certain
diversity inclusion and equity
edicts so these dreadful ideas these
parasitic ideas have real world
consequences they start off in the
esoteric world of the ivory tower but
eventually they break out and now they
infect every nook and cranny of our
societies
i i hope that our audience will take a
look at your book in which you lay this
out in some great detail but i just have
to sum up by asking the obvious question
is this slowing down or is it picking up
steam do you see an end to this
uh i i mean it is uh picking up
regrettably but i am optimistic and that
i truly believe that the silent majority
despises this stuff if we can
activate our inner honey badger and
speak in unison we'll get rid of these
parasitic ideas by next tuesday if we
don't it'll be a slow train ride to hell
what a great i'm glad i asked that
question but a great if we can activate
our inner honey badgers we can end this
by next tuesday but if we don't it's a
train to hell well that's
put that on the fridge
godzilla appreciate your coming on
congrats on the book
thank you so much cheers thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else